madame la Présidente je ne salue pas
madame la Première ministre qui a
peut-être déjà fui le combat
maisdames et messieurs les membres du
gouvernement de l'obstruction
chers collègues
je commence comme je veux c'est la
démocratie chers
que le gouvernement et sa minorité
présidentielle aurait un certain
ras-le-bol d'émotions de censure de mon
groupe parlementaire
j'ai un indice pour vous
cessez d'utiliser le 49-3 et vous
cesserez d'avoir des motion de censure
dans cette hémicycle la temporalité de
cette motion de censure est particulière
car hier soir nous avons assisté à la
débâcle la débâque d'un parti
minoritaire qui a donné à avoir une
Piette image de lui-même non monsieur
Braun ce n'est pas une image choquante
de l'Assemblée nationale c'est une image
inadmissible du gouvernement que nous
avons vu hier
nous étions habitués à vos bassesses à
votre malhonnêteté mais joins la panique
de votre minorité à être mythique vous
avez laissé voir ce qu'il y a de pire en
vous même sur une niche parlementaire
vous avez regorgée d'artifices et
d'imagination pour empêcher le vote du
texte sur la réintégration des
personnels non vaccinés du jamais vu
depuis le début de la cinquième
République
vous avez déployé des manœuvres
démesurées pour mettre un terme au débat
vous êtes méprisant envers le peuple et
sa représentation vous n'avez aucun état
d'âme a laissé des femmes des hommes des
familles dans le plus grand des arroies
vous parlez d'éthique vous n'en avez
aucune vous en appelez à l'altruisme
vous ignorez le sens même de ce mot
lorsqu'ils ne concerne pas votre vivier
des lecteurs ultra-riches
ces vérités sont d'autant plus
flagrantes lorsqu'il s'agit de nos
compatriotes d'outre-mer peu importe ce
qu'ils ont dur vous peignez toujours de
l'ignorer certains hier soir avaient
fait 23 heures de voyage pour
représenter leur peuple vous n'avez même
pas eu une once d'empathie pour eux
vous avez fait pression sur des députés
pour qu'ils ne retirent pas leurs
amendements vous avez déposé des
centaines de sous amendements tous plus
ridicules les uns que les autres
puis nous avons vu arriver monsieur
varan fanfaronnant comme à son habitude
et très fier d'être sorti de son lit
pour user de manœuvre dilatoire s'il
vous plaît au reptile fallu peut-être
expliquer à Monsieur Véran qui n'est
plus ministre de la Santé qu'il a été
remplacé
doit-on lui rappeler aussi que c'est
sous son exercice en tant que ministre
de la santé que des millions de gens ont
été confinés que des soignants
travaillaient dans des conditions
pitoyables que nous n'avions pas de
vaccins ont voulu que les séquelles de
la piètre gestion de la crise covid vont
marquer nos enfants pour des années je
ne vois vraiment pas de quoi il pouvait
être fier
et ce matin
Emmanuel Macron aux expliqué je le cite
nous ne serions pas ravis si un parent
attrape le covid vient un soignant non
vacciné peut-être n'est-il donc pas au
courant qu'aujourd'hui des personnels
potentiellement covides sont déjà au
contact de nos parents comme toujours
pour défendre des décisions ubuesques
vous oubliez la moitié des faits ou
alors vous vous retranchez derrière le
Conseil Scientifique une autorité le
Conseil national d'éthique ou tout autre
instance pourvu que vous puissiez dire
que la décision ne vient pas de vous
mais si vous refusez de prendre des
décisions politiques pourriez-vous nous
expliquer ce que vous faites ici voilà
une raison de plus pour censurer ce
gouvernement au sein de cette Assemblée
une majorité s'est dessinée pour voter
le texte sur la réintégration mais peut
vous importe vous préférez avoir raison
contre tous et utilisez l’obstruction
pour parier votre pour pallier votre
impréparation votre manque de
clairvoyance sur le sujet face à votre
refus de prendre les bonnes décisions
pour notre pays nous ne vous lâcherons
pas ce texte fera son retour dans cette
hémicycle d'une façon ou d'une autre
passez la colère de ne pas pouvoir faire
voter ce texte pour intégrer des
personnels dans nos services publics qui
ont tant besoin face à votre cas
généralisée je le dis ce soir avec
beaucoup plus de sérénité la réalité
c'est que nous avons assisté au
spectacle pathétique d'un parti
présidentiel mis en déroute les
Françaises et les Français vous ont vu
et cette motion de censure a
soudainement pris une autre tournure
face aux franchissement de ligne rouge
nous n'écouterons plus vos élucubrations
sur le changement de méthode ou les
potentiels compromis vos actes sont bien
loin de vos paroles en quelque sorte
tant mieux cela continue de nous de nous
confirmer votre perdition
vous dit vous utilisez des procédés
baillon pour nous empêcher de délibérer
et ne pas dire la vérité aux françaises
et aux Français
madame la Première ministre que je salue
qui vient d'arriver vous avez accusé
notre présidente n'a-t-il pas nous de
mentir lorsqu'elle a alerté sur une
potentielle réforme des retraites dans
le PLFSS en précisant que la menthement
retraite n'était plus dans le texte
mensonge il est en effet dans la partie
sur laquelle nous allons peut-être je
dis bien peut-être débattre tout à
l'heure or une fois le 49-3 passé chacun
sait ici que vous décidez seul de la
version finale du projet de loi notre
alerte est donc amplement justifiée et
au regard du spectacle auquel nous
assistons nous n'avons absolument aucune
raison de vous faire confiance nous vous
parlons de décès sur des brancards morts
au travail fonctionnaire en souffrance
maltraitance de nos aînés mais rien ne
vous fait dévier de votre route vous
cherchez à dissimuler votre casse de la
sécurité sociale et de notre système de
santé par quelques mesures d'apparence
mais vos faux semblants ne plus personne
vous refusez sciemment de trouver des
solutions puis vous voulez faire croire
qu'il n'y a pas d'autre choix vous
répétez sans cesse qu'il n'y a pas
d'argent magique mais pourtant pour une
petite très petite minorité vivant dans
l'opulence la magie opère chaque jour le
financement du système de santé soit
disant hausse mensonge il n'atteint même
pas le niveau de l'inflation
en clair les hôpitaux vont devoir faire
des économies et nous entrevoyons le
pire lorsque nous regardons les
prévisions puisque ce PLFSS devrait être
le plus généreux du quinquennat la
vérité c'est que vous ne prévoyez rien
de véritablement salutaire et
indispensable pour nos concitoyens rien
pour résoudre durablement la crise des
urgences et de l'hôpital rien pour
lutter efficacement contre la pauvreté
rien pour construire un service public
de la petite enfance rien pour mettre un
terme aux dérives des EHPAD abus de
lucratif et pour un véritable service
public de la dépendance
en attendant la France est devenue un
désert médical géant nos concitoyens
sont privés de services d'urgence
beaucoup n'ont pas de médecins traitant
et renoncent à se faire soigner c'est
faux ça non le covid a mis en lumière le
tri des patients qui existent en réalité
depuis longtemps et nous assistons
désemparés même au tri des plus petits
atteints de bronchiolite une honte vous
vivez dans un monde qui n'est pas le
nôtre et qui n'est pas celui de millions
de gens vous n'êtes que les pantins d'un
système bien plus grand que vous mais
pour garder le pouvoir qu'importe vous
êtes prêt à tout vous créez ainsi
dieuzeusement le chaos pour maintenir
les gens dans la peur c'est une méthode
bien rodée mais malheureusement pour
vous nous sommes plus déterminés que
jamais a changé les choses
l'affolement que vous avez montré hier
face à un texte transpartisan qui ne
venait pas de vous nous prouve une chose
votre effondrement est en marche
peut-être pas ce soir peut-être pas
grâce à cette motion mais chaque avancée
compte les gens n'ont plus confiance en
vous cette assemblée de moins en moins
pour dire STOP à l'hypocrisie pour dire
stop au caricature pour dire STOP à vos
mensonges pour dire STOP aux 49-3 et
pour dire STOP à l'obstruction
gouvernementale je suis très fier
d'avoir défendu cette motion de censure
ce soir
je vous remercie
je prends la parole à ce pupitre à
l'issue d'une nouvelle semaine
particulière pour la vie parlementaire
une semaine de contradiction entre
souvent des débats constructifs et des
majorités larges et parfois
reconnaissons le des échanges
d'invectives et des jeux de posture
il y a 5 mois en aiguisant cette
assemblée les Français ont désigné une
majorité et des oppositions
ils nous ont aussi et nous en sommes
tous convenus demandez de travailler
ensemble et de construire des compromis
à l'issue de cette semaine et alors que
nous débattons à nouveau d'une motion de
censure déposée quasiment dans les mêmes
termes par les mêmes députés
issus des mêmes bancs de cette émission
je m'interroge
je m'interroge et j'inclus dans ma
réflexion la majorité les oppositions et
le gouvernement
que voulons-nous retenir de cette
période
cette semaine l'a montré à partir de
désaccords légitimes nous pouvons
basculer dans des jeux de rôles voir des
pugilats mais je suis convaincu que nous
avons encore l'occasion et je dirais
même chacun avec nos convictions la
volonté de répondre à l'attente des
Français et de faire de cette
assembléepicentre du compromis
mesdames et messieurs les députés je ne
me résous pas à la litanie des 49-3
suivi d'émotions de censure alors même
que sur ce texte comme bien comme sur
bien des aspects du PLF nous partageons
des objectifs et des idées comme
l'augmentation de 43 milliards d'euros
du budget de la santé depuis 2019 avant
la pandémie qui comprend un soutien
renouvelé aux hôpitaux ultramarins face
à des difficultés particulièrement
lourdes comme le tournant de la
prévention comme le renforcement des
moyens pour l'autonomie pour les
personnes fragiles je ne m'habitue pas
aux accusations de passage en force qui
m'ignorent le travail parlementaire et
les avancées portaient sur tous les
bancs de cette émission
le texte sur lequel j'ai engagé la
responsabilité de mon gouvernement n'est
pas un copier-coller du projet de loi
initiale il a été amélioré grâce aux
travaux de l'Assemblée nationale je
pense au cumul emploi retraite pour les
médecins ou encore aux exonérations de
charge pour les emplois agricoles il a
été enrichi aussi grâce à vos collègues
sénateurs et je pense notamment sur
cette troisième partie à une mesure pour
inciter les employeurs à proposer des
rachats de RTT alors salariés
mesdames et messieurs les députés je ne
m'habitue pas non plus et je ne
m'habituerai jamais aux attaques
abdominales au procès d'attention aux
contre-vérités et aux excès
depuis près de 30 ans jamais l'Assemblée
nationale n'avait connu une telle
configuration alors oui des habitudes
sont ancrées plutôt que de trouver des
convergences et il est tellement facile
madame la députée Fiat et il est
tellement facile madame la députée
bien oui chacun son tour
après les manœuvres dilatoires de votre
groupe pour examiner subrepticement un
texte important renonçant à trois
propositions de loi que vous aviez
pourtant présenté comme majeur d'accuser
la majorité d'obstruction
madame la député Fiat monsieur ou le
député Neder madame la députée taillée
paulian madame la députée bouroua madame
la députée Bassir vous n'appréciez pas
que la majorité m'est très aussi bien
que vous le règlement intérieur de votre
de votre assemblée
car oui sur le fond nous ne partageions
pas la proposition du groupe insoumi car
oui nous respectons le travail immense
des millions de soignants l'immense
majorité qui conscient de leur
responsabilité et de l'exigence de
protéger les patients se sont fait
vacciner car ils croient en la science
et à la raison
et je dois vous dire une chose j'ai
entendu hier sur certains bancs des
propos glaçons sur la vaccination sur ce
progrès offert par la science
discréditer discréditer la science ou la
chicanée ce n'est pas exalté les
facultés mystiques de l'âme c'est les
appauvriers au contraire et les égarés
disent les Jaurès
appauvrir et garer mesdames et messieurs
les députés je crois précisément que
c'est l'inverse du débat démocratique
voici le résultat du scrutin majorité
requise pour l'adoption de la motion de
censure sur la majorité absolue des
membres composant l'assemblée 289 pour
l'adoption 85 la majorité requise
n'étant pas atteinte la motion de
censure n'est pas adoptée en conséquence
la troisième partie du projet de loi de
financement de la sécurité sociale pour
2023 est considéré comme adopté en
nouvelle lecture